nobody looked more chill to hall-of-fame
ceremonies than Ed Reid I like that he
had his Hall of Fame jacket on he had
cigars in the pocket of the Hall of Fame
jacket I believe in ed Reed joins us now
is that right ed did you have your
cigars there with you yes they gotta
come in there with me
you know it was a part of my maturing
career you know college to the pros you
know I was actually told a story a few
times some aficionados in the cigar and
you know because I'm making my cigar you
know in the process of trying to make my
cigar say guys have been there the whole
time
who did you meet that that you wanted to
meet or kind of took your breath away at
the Hall of Fame ceremonies Oh Mel
Blount ooh
and I'm just sitting sitting talking
with him having conversation with him
and knowing that he lives close to me
which is just really amazing in Atlanta
you know him he and I talking about
playing golf you know so I actually had
a chance to do an interview about him
prior to meeting him be quieter than
many so you know and watch him play
watch some film on Mel Blount
so it was it was honor and you don't
realize that's a big dude to play
defensive back right hey Eddie looks
like he could still play now Mel Blount
so bad did he have his cowboy hat on
Blanco you will see that cowboy hat yeah
he was a bad doom if you could who do
you thinks the best defensive back of
all time the best defensive back of all
time um maybe that guy if you watch
Evelyn - Nell Oh film you know you you
get it you know idea like he was a
safety ahead of his time you know after
I've seen his um film I was blown away
by you know I think Johnny Robinson was
was ahead of his time as well the plays
he's making though
you know the scheme was at the same you
know so I know master that's a heart
that's a tough question to answer it
really is a tough question because one
you know we play a team sport I always
say that and for Tudor was just so many
great you know I mean with you from elf
blood to Ronnie Lott you know the Deion
Sanders where I would sit you know
Charles Woodson who's coming coming up
soon you know and so that's a lot of
argument there is it weird - I mean you
belong in the Hall of Fame but like it
was there any moment where you're
standing up there going I'm in the Hall
of Fame like I'm yeah yeah you know when
when I heard that speech but my dad my
brother you know and and just being back
there and on that red carpet about to
walk across looking across at my dad you
know and it's in tears come on his I've
and it was it was doing surreal man it
was really worth it you what you think
you're like Bill Belichick by mistake in
your Hall of Fame speech did do did you
laugh about it did you know that you
were saying - Belichick no no like a lot
of that was was just there in a moment
you know a lot of it was just there in
the moment as I was enjoying the whole
weekend you know I really I really
wanted that speech to be a bit raw um I
knew it would be a bit wrong you know
and then asked like I said after my
dad's video you know it just kind of
just pour it on out on a really on
appreciation you know of a lot of people
who helped me to get better and have
success at the NFL what was your
relationship like with Tom Brady when
you played it was a quiet one believe it
or not you know always a lot of respect
you know for each other you know Tom
always showed a lot of respect as he um
you know DM me any um a being the
messages on IG you know and I hit him
back so you know it's always kind of
been that that long-distance thing then
you know it was for Brady you know
but soon he'll be a teammate you know so
I'm sure Belichick is right behind him
you know in the Hall of Fame because I'm
on a different team now and you know we
seem to be recruiting these days do you
want to coach with the Patriots have you
had an offer from Bella tractor coach no
just he and I had a conversation about
about me um I told him I was I thought
about putting the offer to take his DB
job and he was blown away by that but um
I don't know you know I know that Coach
would be somebody I wouldn't I was in my
I wouldn't mind learning to be a better
coach though I learned so much from
watching him you know and understand him
knowing you know we'll have to win the
championship you know knowing what it
took to win a championship you know I
mean I I was I had a lot of the coach
ear should I say when I played and I
think coaches could have tested that on
the conversations we've had you know how
barb told you like relationship that we
had have should I say now you know have
a lot of respect for coach for what he's
done you know so just watching coach
Belichick over the years you know
interviews would you have you his book
you know read his book and just just how
he conducted you know things for his
team helped me to be a better leader you
know of my team he said read the Ravens
Hall of Fame safety joining us Dan
Patrick show toughest opponent any
position you faced toughest opponent
man's gotta be had it was no doubt about
it the running backs I played against in
the AFC North you know in in some of the
AFC you know we had we had a bunch of
great running backs you know from the
Jerome Bettis who was a hall-of-famer
you know the Corey Dillon court for
Cincinnati you know it was just so many
guys that I played again you know our
murmur play to get Stevie
and the crack of m1 alone on the
sideline man he was a big guy he's
brought remember he broke out on the
left sideline of defensive left sideline
in Atlanta and I had to tackle him by
myself man you know so this is a lot of
respect for running back obviously the
receivers you know these guys were
handfuls you know Chad Johnson twice a
year practical barriers you know Hines
Ward Hines was definitely my nemesis on
the football field without a doubt what
kind of running back would you have made
at because whenever you you had an
interception
you weren't content with just an
interception you wanted to score a
touchdown and you were really good at it
[Music]
you know I give that to other guys
though I wouldn't back down for a minute
how to play running back you know I love
the ball in my hand obviously saw that
when when I when I when I caught
interception there was about getting in
the end zone and you know honestly damn
and I wanted to play defense you know
I'm playing quarterback too and a
receiver but I wanted to play defense
why because those guys didn't know how
to talk how much do you love your Hall
of Fame bust Oh dad you know mister
bushwell
Mr Blair busts were his wife there's
such an awesome job with that I knew it
was going to look like that you know and
I was I was proud proud of it like it
was it really showed Who I am for one
but that was me during my career you
know that was me during football you
know anyone who know me you know know I
always have hair on my head when I came
into the league and I went to Baltimore
guys I did go leading up to the Hall of
Fame the day I got drafted I have braids
in my hair if you ever got a picture of
it I had braids and by the end of the
night I had took the braids out you know
and it was kind of a Miami thing that we
used to do actually posted it on my
Instagram my hair
blown out and and next day I had to fly
to Baltimore I flew to Baltimore and I
remember I was looking at me like Oh
Lord who we dropped it because my hair
was all over my head and if you go back
to my dreading interview with the Ravens
I got on a Ravens collared shirt Ravens
are Ravens coaches collared shirt and
the Ravens coaches slacks
you know so I came into the league of
coach Oh believe it or not and so they
asked me to braid my hair miss Val the
Secretary had to uh personally braided
my hair you know for a fact forward to
the Hall of Fame I did the same thing
took my hair out because I always have
my hair up when I play sports when I
play basketball football you know and it
was just something a part of me you know
you know that bus mr. Blair there was
phenomenal phenomenal phenomenal you
know work that you did for that art that
ready yeah yeah by the way Edie read
foundation.org you can find out what
he's doing with it doing wonderful
things a park is being built in Ed's
childhood neighborhood it was a great
speech ed you know incorporating your
parents and all the people who played a
role in all this and getting you to this
final result with the Hall of Fame it
was wonderful to see and maybe we'll
have a cigar here down the road
Thank You ed a Vanna room in New York
City
dance have been there for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]